Merhabalar ben Ama çok uzun bir zamandır
peterpan diye Karol aldığım için Artık
peterpan olarak
geçiyorum petanın hikayesinden
başlayacağım biraz nasıl
cemiy bundan
yaklaşık bir buç sene
önce Hast tık
ça
kanseri ağ ilerle bir kanser
çok cevap
vermiyor İlk
ttı
gi
GD
[Müzik]
haar papağan var mavi ben o papağanı
istiyorum ona bir şey söyleyeceğim ve
herim gerçek olacak ded şimdi Afrika
papağı Türkiye'de işte nereden bulacağız
nasıl edeceğiz say o zaman yoktu ama biz
bu iş yapmaya devam
ediyorduk Facebook üzerinden duy
başladık çocuk için fotoğrafı da
kullanmadık Afrika arıyoruz
mavi
papağan bulundu ama yani bir haft bir
süre
geç buradaki fotoğra papağan gördüğü
andaki fotoğrafı o sürede hastalığı
ilerlediği için eve gönderildi tedavisi
kesildi ertes doğum günüydü
diğ Günen
[Müzik]
fotoğraflar çok fazla varsı vardı kanser
TP ilerlediği için çok hız rahat
çekiyordu Ve hasta eve göndermesi bebe
diğer çocuktan etkileniyor
olması deim inanılmaz bir şey bu yani
minicik bir şey yaptık bir tane kuş
getirdik ve gerçekten beni odadan
çıkardı ona bir şey söyledi Eee ve bu
çocuğun hayatı değişti Yusuf bunan ik
hafta sonra hayatını kaybetti
fotoğraflardan sonra e il iki haftam çok
depresyonla geçti dedim Hiçbir şeye
yaramıyor hiçbir şey yapamıyorum
çocuklar
ölüyorlar sonra Fotoğrafları gördüm
Tekrar ve dedim ki asa çok büyük bir şey
yapıyoruz biz çocuklar için bir muze
yatmıyoruz belki hayatların da devam
etmi sağlayamıyoruz ama hayatlarında bir
günü gerçekten çok sevdiklerini onlar
için her şey yapabileceğini göstererek
geçiriyoruz O bugün onlar için çok
değerli Çünkü bir de gün daha
olmayabilir bir saat daha
olmayabilir asıl başlangıç noktamız
Yusuf oldu n panlar cemiye benim isimas
yaparak Zaman isim koyarak kurduğum Cem
yıldır Facebook üzerinden sadece
faaliyette yine bir hata yaptım ve
sosyal medyayı iyi kullanıp basın
yönetimi yapamadım Biz kurulduktan Bir
ay sonra fan yaklaşık beyaz
çıkt beyazdan 30.000 yak takipçi geldi
30.000 takipçi insanlardan çok fazla
insan varmış arkamızda izlerini yarattı
Eee benim inandığım şey şuydu iyi
insanlar azalmıyor iyi insanlar atlara
binip gitmediler
Eee insanların kötü leğe doğru gitmiyor
insanlık batmakta değil dünya da
batmıyor Evet çok fazla savaşlar var çok
fazla kayıplar veriyoruz nefret çok
artıyor
gös gibi insanlar
şeğ
oliz
b00
dü statümü yok hiçbir gelir kaynağımız
yok hiçbir çalışanımız yok ben varım e
mailleri kontrol eden çocuklar me küçü
dediğ İrem var E bu 1700 çocuk ağırlıklı
olarak Nadir gören hastalıkları bulunan
ve ende sonunda kaybedeceğimiz çocuklar
bunlara tıbbi destek e ameliyatları için
y tıbbi destek hayallerini
gerçekleştirdiğimiz çocuklar var eee
[Müzik]
birun bu sre ınd
Ben
kal bur
IR bir kiş
[Müzik]
tt7
ins
bu çuk için bir şey yapmaya
çalışıyorlar Bir sonraki
[Müzik]
fotoğrafta tuçe
mesela için
bekliyor ağır
kalı hastaneden
[Müzik]
çıkamıyor
birı için sayfaya bir yazı Yazım ki bu
akşam patates doğması gelmesi
lazım niler nelin yaptığı üü patates
olması istiyor Bir buç saat sonra beni
hiç tanımayan bir insan annesine 56
yaşındaki
annesine karşıda oturmalar rağ patası
yaptırmış ve geçmişti hastaneye sadece
paylaşılan bir fotoğraf
yüzünden çok zor dönemler geçiyoruz s
olarak Çünkü Eee ciddi ihtiyaçları var
Bu
çocukların ciddi paralar gerektiren
durumlar var devletin ne yazık ki
destekliği köstek olduğu durumlar var
ailelerin bilgisizliği var elimizde
olmayan çaresizlikler var hastanelerde
yarılması tedavi bulamaması Türkiyeli
ilacı olmaması gibi
Eee bunlara rağmen öyle şeyler oluyor ki
Eee devam etmek gücü veriyor bana ve
sayfadaki diğer insanlara
eee Suriyeliler Türkiye'ye gelmeye
başladığında ben Rusya'da Balat'ta
yaşıyordum inanılmaz bir Suriyeli çocuk
kurası sayfaya dahil oldu işte Her gün
gidip kontrol etmek durumunda kaldığım
ağır Hastalık olan bebekler de vardı ve
ben orada bir duyuru yaptım e dedim ki
bu çocuklar kendilerini çok yalnız
hissediyorlar kimse hissediyorlar Çünkü
bir savaştan bir kaostan geldiler ve
ailelerini kaybettiler Yani hiçbir
akrabalık ilişkileri kalmadı Yeni doğan
bebekler de var Lütfen bu çocuklar için
bir fır
Çünkü benim gözümde işte ölülü bir
hırkası olan bir bebek ailesi olduğunun
göstergesi Yeni doğan bebekleri Bizim
kültürümüzde işte hırka patik
örür 36.000 yakın hırka ve patik
geldi
huzurevinden
9899 yaşında örgü örüp gönderenler var
Örgü örmeyi bilmiyordum kursa gittim o
yüzden yetiştiremedim geciktim diyenler
var ve ben bu insanlar Hiçbirini
tanımıyorum
ve Bence dernek vakıf olmayan bir
topluluk olarak yani 57 insan olarak
yaptığınız en güzel şeylerden biri yas
Efe
veur y ve Hur ikiz
kardeşler Eee SMA denilen bir
hastalıkları var SMA Bir genetik nen Bir
genetik hastalık tedavisi yok ölüm yaşı
olarak 5 deniliyor 5 yaşına kadar
maksimum yaşayabilecekleri söyleniyor ve
makineye bağlıdan geçiyorlar süre
boyunca Biz hastanede
tanıştığımızda Yasin Efe evdeydi annesi
iki bebeğe Ayn anda bakamadığı için Hur
hastanedeydi hastanede kalıyordu yoğa
durum gitti ağırlaşıyor bir anne ilgisi
görm için ne yapalım ne edelim diye
düşünürken İşte bu yani konuşm da yok
öyle bir şey diye başlık attı şey
oldu Ben dedim ki bir ev hemşire tutalım
bir hemşir maşım düzenli olarak ikisi
bir araya gelsinler Çünkü anne de
perişan bir çocuğunu hastanede
bırakmaktan dolayı çocuğun durumu
ağırlaşıyor kardeşini ölüyor diye
ikizler beraber
Büyümüşler işte ftır 16 ayl gi
hsın y sağ
baksın şe
ol gir Bir Haa son
hemş yaklaş
[Müzik]
AYD
fotoğrafları ve enteresan bir şekilde
hastanın ilerlemesi
durdu
Eee tekrar Gent tesine gidecekler Eğer
çok iyi bakımdan kaynaklanan bir durum
yoksa şayet
Eee
Sayfada şu ana kadar giden çocukların
neredeyse hepsiyle ilgili çok ciddi
süreçler yaşadık mey Bunlardan
biri ve yas E bana gerçekten arkamda Ne
kadar insan olduğumu gösterdi Ne kadar
çok insanın burada ben de ya Efe ve ay
Hi
görmedim Ne kadar çok insanın görmed ve
çocuklar için neler yapabildiğini göster
Çünkü yas ve hın parası sayfadaki
destekçiler tarafından toplanıyor hiçbir
sponsorumuz yok bana gelen mesajlar
arasında öğrenci kursunu gönderdiğini
söyleyenler
var maaşını gönderenler var çocuğuma
ayakkabı alacaktım benim çocuğum da
spastik bu ayaı almasam da olur Onun
parasını gönderirim diyenler
var para yatırmaya gidecek Yol param
yoktu o
yüzden geciktim 10 lira gönderiyorum ama
umarım kalkıs olur diyenler var nefsi
çoğalan derken görmek istediğim şey
buydu
e sayfada birçok insan benim için Melek
diyor ve ben de iddia ediyorum ki ben
Melek değil
benim yaptığım şeyi yapan bir sürü insan
var ve buna da devam ediyorlar sadece
birbirlerini bulamıyorlar birbirlerini
göremiyorlar
e ve Aslında biz toplum olarak da
yardımlaşmayı seven güçlü bir toplumuz
Sadece birbirimizin farkına varamıyoruz
Bu sayfada yaptığım şeyin amacı
kesinlikle çocukları hayatta tutmak
değil kesinlikle mucize yarattığımı
iddia etmiyorum kesinlikle mucize
yatacağımız da söylemiyorum bir destekte
biz
sadece E nefsimizin çoğaldığını iyi
insanların hala aramızda olduğunu iyi
insanların gerçekten bir şeyler yapmak
istediklerinde ne kadar büyük bir fark
yaratabilirler
Eee ve ölüyorlar da olsa sonunda o
çocuklar için bir günün ne kadar önemli
olduğunu göstermeye
çalışıyoruz
Eee Burada da karşımıza bazı sorunlar
çıkıyor Ben artık onları tanımlıyorum
başka bir efsaneden biz peterpan
hikayesine
inanıyoruz ama tarihte
e
[Müzik]
ha denizde bir yer bir gme
karşısın
yarık cdi sesleri insan ETK
var engelliyorlar Bizim hayatım benim
hayatımda silenler Hayal kurmaya
başladığınızda karşınıza çıkıyorlar ve
diyorlar ki
yapamazsın ben bu sayfayı kurmaya
kalktığın zamana demişlerdi ki çok
yanacaksın bir sene içerisinde
delireceksin dayanma gücün kalmayacak ve
hiçbir şeye yaramayacak yaptığın
şeyler şu an sayfada 57000 takipçisi
olmasına rağmen çok cdi az bir
destekçisi var Ancak buna rağmen 460
tane çocuğa düzenli olarak aylık Gıda ve
ilaç yardım yapıyoruz Eee 1700 çocuk
bizim kontrolümüzde Eee ağır şiddet
görmüş ve töne Madur olan iki farklı
anne ve çocuğunun ayrlık Eee kira ve ki
ihtiyaçlarını karşılıyoruz Yasın
masraflarını karşılıyoruz
Eee ve arkamızda hiçbir sponsor yok dev
sponsor firmalarından ve şirketlerden
maddi yardım almıyoruz Eee devlet köstek
olmadığı sürece Aramız iyi Eee ama bizi
tanımıyor Vakıf değiliz Dernek değiliz
çalışanımız yok Facebook üzerinden devam
ediyoruz ve bu da ben Melek olduğum için
olmuyor gerçekten bu ülkede hala ii
insanlar var olduğunu siliyor ve bu yine
biz s sesen duymadığımız için oluyor
Eee sayfada bana Melek denmesinin
sebeplerinden biri
de çocuklarla olan
ilişkim
yine kaybettiğimiz çocuklardan biri
benim oyunu arkadaşım
Meyra ö 3
yaşındaydı biz sen Tamam beraber
geçirdik istediği her şey
yapıldı bu baler olmak istiyordu kı
özç
[Müzik]
uemi istiyordu onu
yapmadık daha çok çocukla vakit
geçirebilme
gidebilirsin evine gitmemi istiyordu
Çünkü benim evimde engelli 11 kedi ve 9
Köpek Var
baktım Çünkü senin de çocukların var
diyordu insanlar da diyordu ki sirenler
Hem çocuk sevip hem hayvan bakamazsın
Ben Meydan o insanların seslerini de
duymayı öğrendim
meın Bir de evde bekle dedi bana artık
kardeşleri var süreyi çüz bir kısmı
benimle beraber
yaşıyorlar Bu da bir sayfayı kurduktan
sonra tanımadığım bir insan
tarafından internete eklenen bir yazı
Peter fen asa çocukları elinden tutup
cennete götüren bir melekti Bu yüzden
çocuklar hiç büyüyorlar çünkü çocuklar
ölüydü ölüm acı tarafı işin biraz önce
Mert Bey hepimizi güldürdü Ben de
suratınızı düşürdüm çok özür D diyorum
Eee bu çocuklar Evet ölüyorlar Hepimizin
öleceği gibi bir gün ama bu çocukların
hayatında fark yaratabiliyor yfe ve Hüma
hastanede birbirlerini hiç görmeden
anneleri de hiç
Eee görüşemedim yoğun bakım altında da
ölebilirler şu an beraberler Eee 5 bu5
aydır birlikte her Saf uyanıyorlar ve bu
onlar için çok
değerli
Meyra yine keza öyle son bir senesini
tanıdım her çocuktan her ihtiyacı
karşılanan her çocuktan çok daha iyi
geçirdi Çünkü hastaneden çıkmak isted
hastaneden çıkardık oyun arkadaşı oyun
arkadaşı bulduk gece baklava tuta gece
2. baklava getirdik ve bunlar sadece
benim gibi masallara inanan insanlar
sayesinde
oldu Çok büyük bir şey yapmıyorum O
yüzden Niye Yani niye bu konuşmada
burada Ben duruyorum Onu bilmiyorum
Sadece şu anlatmak istedim hayatınızda
her zaman karşınıza sirenler çıkacaklar
her zaman Birileri size bunu yapamaz
diyecek her zaman biril bu çok tehlikeli
diyecek her zaman bire bu yasal değil
diyecek Lütfen kendinizi dinlemeye devam
edin lütfen hayallerinizin peşinden
Gitmeye devam edin lütfen insanların
olduğuna inanmaya devam edin lütfen
çocukların çocukken Okuduğunuz
masalların gerçekliğine inanmaya devam
edin Ve inanıyorum ki Evet her şey çok
kötü çok fazla
Faz nefret
var Dünya çok iyi olmayan bir noktaya
doğru gidiyor ama inanıyorum ki Sonik
kazanacak Yeter ki biz iyilikten yana
olmaktan iyilik yapmaktan vazgeçmeyelim
Bu bir yardımseverlik değil konuşmanın
başlığı da buydu zaten yardım değil bu
insan olarak yapmamız gereken şey bu
hepimiz aynı gemiz Gem gibi hepiz a y
gidiyoruz hepiz birbirimize kluz hepimiz
aynı hayatta nefes aldığımız sürece
Birbirimize destek olmakla yükümlüyüz
arkamızda devlet olmasına gerek yok Eee
organizasyonlar olmasına gerek yok
cebimizde Milyonlar olmasına gerek yok
biz birbirimize yetebilen bir toplumuz
birbirimize yetebilen insanlarız bunu
hatırlayalım Çok teşekkür ediyorum Mein
dediğiniz
için
i